when do you expect your banking
relationships to be restored well I hope
as soon as possible die
you know we've got 7500 staff members
and the immediate families which I would
estimate to be about 60,000 people
really worried about their futures I
listen to some of them calling in local
radio stations over the weekend
imploring the banks do to do to step up
to the plate and resume normal relations
with ourselves I hope that I can get
some appointments with the bank's this
morning and convince them to the to
restore our relations are you talking to
the same institutions that have walked
away from you are you talking to new
possible financial institutions that
could work with you give us some names
here who has walked away from you and
who do you expect to be re-establishing
relationships with or establishing
relationships with well in the South
African context therefore major banks
all four have walked away from us we
need one of them at least to offer some
kind of services so we'll be talking to
all four banks again this week and
assuring them of our governance being in
place the correctness of what we've done
and and really we can implore them to
think about our workers that's the 7,500
in the immediate families that is really
what matters today is that their
livelihoods are not affected by this
decision you confirmed last week that
you had contacted various government
officials to try and assist you in
reestablishing these relationships I'm
really curious about this why did you
think that that was a good course of
action given the fact that it's this
political business link that seems to be
at the heart of this story and what kind
of reaction did you get when you
contacted those officials well you know
let me start off why did we do it very
simply to save jobs South Africa's major
challenge today is jobs and job creation
and were 7,500 jobs at risk it was do
whatever it takes to get that going
that was the only reason for writing to
the institution's the Minister of
Finance is politically responsible for
the banking sector and it's
unprecedented for for banking
institutions the four major banking
institutions to all walk away from a
business it's never happened in this
country it's never happened I think in
the world that the major banking
institutions would do something like
this
so it was really to plea for or for some
kind of assistance and guidance on how
we can try and restore those
relationships no other reason that we
would do that
what responsive we've had very little
right now from those incident from that
little leadership but we will continue
to do whatever it takes will speak to
whatever it we can business
organizations political organizations
the banks themselves community
organizations to to really plea for the
jobs of our people mr. hower Hots
Nichols here in Berlin you say you're
gonna be reaching out to those four
banks how much time are you giving
yourself to restore relations is there
is there any sort of time limit here are
we talking days or weeks well the banks
have given us until the end of May so
we've we've got a couple of weeks to get
to get either the relationships restored
or caught under the plan but you know
without the four major banks we very
clear in our heads that the jobs are at
risk and in fact I think you know with
one of our businesses we may need to
take some drastic measures this week was
that business works with all four banks
and its revenues will be infected
immediately that the banking services
are overthrown so there we may need to
take some some very serious and drastic
steps this week already of one of our
businesses what is what is all about
this is you've already highlighted as is
four major banks walking away from a
company on mass that strikes you I'm
sure as odd that strikes me I think as
odd what do you think sparked this was
there coordination between these banks
was there pressure put on them by
somebody else the third party for them
to walk away to the new piece of
information become available why did it
happen so suddenly and with all four
major banks being involved at the same
time well I you know I want in two ways
I got asked by one of the editors of one
of the major financial institutions
whether we believe there's a third force
at end we don't have any concrete
evidence of that so I I don't want to
make that assumption that what sumption
was made by the editor financial mail
but you know clearly as I say it's
unprecedented it's never happened before
and you know particularly in a country
where we've had major
and scandals where the bends have never
taken those tips against any other
business we the first business had
suffered this kind of action but the
second point I would make to you is that
what surprises us is this this very
strong action is taken against a
backdrop of not a single charge being
laid against us no evidence of any
corruption or anything else and you know
South Africa prides itself on having a
once wonderful Constitution which
presumes you innocent until proven
guilty it would seem that our 7500 staff
members and if they lively which they've
taken away must be able to say that
we've been punished for something we've
not done anything about we've not been
guilty of anything but 7,500 people are
likely to lose their jobs because of
this decision taken for reasons best
known to the banks not to ourselves so
mr. Howe how will you will you go to the
bank so you meet with them in the coming
days is your argument about the job
losses or are you gonna be making a
fundamentally different argument to them
how are you gonna convince them to
restore relations I really will start
with the job losses because that's the
most important thing to me we like a
family of the 7,500 staff or our family
for them and the immediate families to
be impacted by this decision is really
something that we want to avoid at all
costs my first plea will be around the
issue of job losses my second argument
will be around the issue of we're making
decisions against a backdrop of no
concrete evidence or no concrete finding
these events anyone in the group anybody
in the shielding structure anything else
and that surely if we believe in the
constitutional democracy we all talk
about sobra so broadly we must assume
innocent until proven guilty and not
simply moving and and really create a
stranglehold around our business to
force us out of business and to lose
these 7,500 jobs just to follow up on
that point though what it's the guptas
relationship with the business that
obviously is causing the financial
institutions their concern and their
concern surrounding the political
scandal do you think that the action
taken thus far by your shareholder is
enough to convince the banks or do you
think that actually you will you guys
are going to need to talk about maybe
your shareholder divesting the stake in
the business
well I think that's not a decision for
me to take that's a shell the decision
on whether I want to divest or not and
there's no indication at this point that
they want to do that but I think you
know from our point of view I think the
shelters have taken what I think is a
big sacrifice they've made a big
sacrifice to save the 7,500 jobs and I
would argue that that should be enough
for the banks who do the right thing to
save these jobs right now okay have you
spoken to the shareholder over the last
what have you spoken to the shareholder
since Friday he's spoken to the Gupta
since Friday no I've not I've no up not
they've taken the decision to to
distance himself from the business and
they've lived up to that decision and
they've left us as the management team
to take charge of the business on a
day-to-day basis do you if you need to
talk to them do you know where they are
certainly I know where they are they've
not in hiding they've not fled the
country so I certainly I know where they
are but the decision they've taken is
that the management will run the
business and they've entrusted us with
every single decision